hello and welcome to this video playing
akito his london player so i'm going to
directly address that was c5 you cannot
do much against him ultimately but then
i came risking a little bit here maybe
if it takes you five I don't quite know
how to get the bond back but ok it
doesn't do it if this an idea and I am
trying to do something else against this
opening so probably not that great
actually but what I'm doing here it will
see
[Music]
now that's a bit unconventional maybe it
can irritate some a bit you know um I
don't know how good it is objectively
what I'm doing him quite know why what
would think here we should be eight I
don't believe in that move at all but
maybe maybe you can do that see takes
looks extremely normal well here 93 wavy
was an idea yeah 93 be five sir what
could irritate me here so maybe let's
get development going you might be 5 i'm
just going to cancel if he decides to do
it
I can't go night before myself in some
cases
now it usually should lead to all that
much let's see what is doing in general
in those kind of somewhat slowish London
position a key virtue is just patients
here sometimes have those positions
where nothing much is going on and just
have to be a bit patient and try to find
little things that you can play warm
okay I don't know if a success any good
chair but i think i think i'm going to
do it if he puts the bishop back I mean
he probably will I am taking on c6 looks
extremely strange giving me a bishop
pair for nothing then maybe not before
even though I don't quite see if this is
this has any point yeah but this is a
good structure right for white or black
look at this that looks like a good
structure now you should prove but where
does he retweet division I mean night
c4i okay I cannot go b5 he will take
this because of the pin but Bishop c4 I
can go oopsie age and then I'm
threatening be five winning the t5 porn
check it should be a pretty good ending
both captures actually are interesting
this is interesting because there is
this yeah I think I'll do that the night
95 is a really nice addition of option
here that it's not that easy to play
against if I do this now 95
what do I have something better you
don't think so but this looks good that
should probably win some stuff yeah this
is winning at least upon but maybe I can
get more right upon is good through
let's take the pond it's also pretty
nice structure now okay 93 even comes
and comes into consideration it's not it
doesn't have a lot of good squares the
Knights here are pretty nice some night
somewhere I look somewhere I mean I
think I can do that it's pretty big bit
awkward yeah look everyone it probably
has to play no it just gives me the
exchange okay white resides here to play
with a phone it was better for black but
not a disaster I mean yeah with the good
technique it should be a decisive
advantage but ok so let's have a look
there I'm not quite sure about my my my
player this is a bit of a risky way of
playing because I mean why can't take
this pawn and it's not so clear that you
get it back I mean probably I would have
played this but something like that
isn't easy to get to play against I mean
I this is a fairly normal position of
would be a fairly normal position
with the night already being on f6 out
of the reti opening but your blog is a
pawn down the tempo down on the other
hand this is an open diagonal it's tough
the same but he played its normal London
roof and him night x given by stockfish
that's an interesting idea yeah
definitely I didn't really take this all
that much into account like could be 695
m 9 a-6 interesting interesting that
that could easily be better for
wide-ranging likes white him my position
is a little bit awkwardly coordinated
yeah I say I was kind of doubting if my
opening player was all that good I think
this doesn't do all that much positive
here for him and definitely I think here
this this d5 this is the wrong idea that
just doesn't doesn't add up especially
giving giving me this fantastic diagonal
can cannot be right I thought you would
just like go back I mean not that he
needs to because I'm not attacking the
bishop but in general I put it here Tim
and I'm quite ok with this position but
it's nothing special and his chest he's
losing and losing the coordination quite
a bit yeah and ok yeah I was kind of
suspecting that putting something to do
three could be even better than grabbing
but this is just a good porn that's
nothing wrong with taking it yeah here
look f1
we played then I'm just continuing here
Kingda seven or something yeah and you
can it is just a pawn and nothing
nothing else there's no compensation
whatsoever ok guys thanks for watching